DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello, again.
I'm Dustin Kirkland.
I'm joined now by Yoshi Tamura,
Product Manager at Google.
And we are here to
talk about gVisor.
So gVisor-- brand new,
just open-sourced this week
at KubeCon here in Copenhagen.
Give me the highlights
of that announcement.
YOSHI TAMURA: Yes, so Google
Cloud just announced gVisor.
It is a new open-source
sandbox technology
for container isolation.
It is very lightweight, yet
provide a very strong isolation
compared to various
[INAUDIBLE] approaches.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Interesting.
So you said it's new.
It's new to the
open-source community.
This is technology that's
been in use at Google
for quite some time, right?
YOSHI TAMURA: Correct.
We have been using gVisor
at Google for a while.
And we're very excited to
share the technology and also
the knowledge that
we gain from there.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, so why are we
at Google open-sourcing
this project now?
YOSHI TAMURA: It is mainly
because container adoption--
Docker, Kubernetes.
Now, a lot of people
are using containers.
And the more people
use containers,
we started seeing a
lot of new use cases,
especially multi-tenancy,
where there's
one cluster with different types
of groups or even customers.
Now, the container
isolation becomes
more important in this
kind of situation.
We believe that
open-sourcing gVisor, which
is a new proposal to the
open-source community
could advance the technology in
this container isolation space.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So it's
really about the security.
It's about sandboxing some
containers-- all containers?
Some containers?
YOSHI TAMURA: Specifically on--
you could definitely specify.
But if you specify that
you want stronger isolation
for a particular
container, yes, you
can actually do the [? show. ?]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
And how strong is
this isolation?
Is it as strong as a VM?
YOSHI TAMURA: We believe that
is kind of a very closer level,
for sure.
The other aspect,
I think, strong
and the lightweight part.
In our testing
environment, it can
launch within 150 millisecond.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: 150
milliseconds to launch?
YOSHI TAMURA: Exactly.
And also, the footprint
is about 15 megabytes.
So it is very lightweight, and
yet provide a strong isolation.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Super lightweight.
So compare that lightweight
to, say, QMU, KVM, Kata.
YOSHI TAMURA: Yes, so there
are existing approaches
like the ones that
you mentioned.
You can definitely
put the container
inside a virtual
machine to provide
a very strong isolation.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
Is that what gVisor is?
YOSHI TAMURA: It is
actually very similar.
But if you look into the
detail where you can look--
please look at the blog.
It actually highlights
the key differences there.
But in a nutshell,
the virtual machine,
you actually need to
run, QMU [INAUDIBLE]
device [? simulate ?] and
also the guest kernel.
Therefore the footprint plus
also the attacking surface
is still significant enough.
gVisor took a little
bit different approach,
where you trap the system
calls and then provide
multiple layers of security.
This is, I think, the
great part of the gVisor.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Yeah, interesting.
So do you actually run a kernel
inside of the gVisor machine?
YOSHI TAMURA: It is a
very tricky question.
So I strongly recommend
going to the blog.
It's a very novel and innovative
approach that I think is--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Sys calls
are being trapped, though?
YOSHI TAMURA: Yes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And those are being
executed by the host kernel.
YOSHI TAMURA: Actually, so
there is a guest user LAN
kernel that will drive this.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Microkernel.
YOSHI TAMURA: It is
not a microkernel
from a technical perspective.
Again, it's a very new approach
and it's very creative.
We also reached out to the Kata
container community about this.
They were also very welcome.
And as you can see
in a blog post,
we also got the quotes
from their team.
So I think--
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
You think there's
an opportunity for
the two projects
to really come together and
advance the state of the art?
YOSHI TAMURA: I think that
is the most exciting part.
This feels so important
for our ecosystem.
And taking different
approaches is definitely
going to advance the
field altogether.
So that is the most exciting
part of why we're open-sourcing
and what we look for
toward the future.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And if someone
wants to get started with this,
what's the best
place to get started?
So we also have, I guess,
the Getting Started section
in our blog.
But, certainly, yes.
Going from GitHub, you can
download the source code.
gVisor is implementing OCI.
Therefore, it runs on with
Kubernetes and Docker.
So if you're interested, just
go to GitHub and try out.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
it's another runtime
that Kubernetes supports,
or will support.
YOSHI TAMURA: So
the runtime itself,
[? or ?] command is
call runsc, which
is where you can replace
the existing runc
and drop in a replacement.
So you are familiar
with those concepts,
you should be able to
run it very quickly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Sure.
And if I do this, can
I run some containers
in the same Kubernetes with
runc and some containers
at a runsc context?
YOSHI TAMURA: Right now,
the Kubernetes community,
especially, [? should ?]
know that we're specifying
the higher-level API
[? call ?] sandbox.
So until that gets
into Kubernetes,
you may have to [INAUDIBLE] some
manual points to control that.
But we believe
that integration is
going to come to the
Kubernetes world very quickly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's great.
That's great.
So I've got a question for you.
How did you get
started in Kubernetes?
YOSHI TAMURA: It's
a great question.
I will say two points.
When I joined Google,
I was very excited
about the internal
system called Borg.
So Kubernetes, based off of
Borg or derived from Borg
is some kind of a
way that I got more--
I got the knowledge
after getting Google.
The other aspect,
which is interesting,
is before I joined
the Kubernetes team,
I went to Tokyo.
One of my friends were
saying, I'm using Kubernetes.
I actually didn't know about
Kubernetes at that time.
So that was how I learned
about Kubernetes in 2017.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Interesting.
And another question for you.
You're involved in the
Kubernetes community.
Certainly encounter a
lot of people in our very
large and open community.
Can you tell us a few of the
people that inspired you,
that you find yourself working
with and being super impressed,
and appreciative of?
YOSHI TAMURA: Absolutely.
A little bit hesitating
to highlight my colleague
at Google, but it is
definitely a truth,
so Dawn Chen has been
inspiring me quite a bit.
I work with her on gVisor, and
also various Kubernetes stuff.
She has a very strong
and visionary technical
insight, and also very
good communication.
So it's just a joy
to work with her.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Well, great.
Yoshi, thank you very much.
YOSHI TAMURA: Thank
you very much, Dustin.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Domo arigato.
YOSHI TAMURA: Domo arigato.